We're going to collabs lecture eight and
nine together
since there's no class on the 27th.
Bsa is now due on the third of April,
the next day.
So just after reading.
Okay.
I suppose for the next essays,
although once again you're
obliged to pick your own topic,
some use,
some reliance on the secondary meetings
would probably be useful because one of
the things that concerns me is that
people aren't going to do the secondary
reading since we don't talk much about
the in class since I don't make it a
point of pestering you with exams or
such.
Regarding the secondary readings,
they are important.
Um,
did I want to ask you,
did I go over in this class the purpose
of each of the readings?
No.
Okay.
I did that my other class.
I'll do that now.
Do you want to tell you why I wanted you
to read what I outlined?
Well,
the purpose of the neuropsychological
papers that does everybody have their
syllabus.
Okay,
good.
The purpose of the neuropsychological
papers is pretty much obvious to get to
give you some additional material
bearing on neuro psychology to sort of
flesh out the additional discussion.
Okay.
Newman's book,
the origins and History of consciousness
provides the best overview that I know
of here on mythology.
The most accurate overview.
It's a book that's much like Joseph
Campbell's hero with a thousand faces,
except I think it's the.
See the problem with Joseph Campbell is
that he's too optimistic he'll.
For Campbell,
the hero's journey is something that's
always positive and I don't think that's
true.
I think it's more.
Well,
I mean the standard hero myth in Western
culture is Christ's passion that
involves
exposure to a hostile group,
torture and then dad.
So
that aspect of the hero myth at least
could not be construed as particularly
positive.
So anyways,
I,
I think that new ones work is for
original
and the great mother.
While the reason that I want you to read
the great mother is because.
Let me read you something from ham here.
First would be a good introduction to
this.
I like this quote because a Donald Hebb
is extraordinarily well regarded by
physiological psychologist.
He was the person who originated the
hypothesis that I'm of neural networks
basically and um,
suggested that learning occurred as a
consequence of potentiation,
of the communication between neurons.
Anyways,
head states,
even in ourselves.
Civilized,
amiable and admirable parts of mankind
well brought up and not constantly in a
state of fear.
There are signs that this or that,
it depends as much on our successfully
avoiding disturbing stimulation as on a
lower sensitivity has already suggested
the capacity for emotional breakdown,
maybe self concealing leaving the animal
to find or create an environment in
which the stimuli to excessive emotional
responses are at a minimum.
So effective is our society in disregard
that it's members,
especially the well to do and educated
ones may not even guess at some of their
own potential realities.
One usually thinks an education in the
broad sense that's producing a
resourceful emotionally stable adult
without respect to the environment in
which these traits are to appear.
To some extent,
this may be true,
but education can be seen as being also
the means of establishing a protective
social environment in which emotion
instability as possible.
Perhaps it strengthens the individual
against unreasonable fears and rages,
but it's certainly produces the
uniformity of appearance and behavior
which reduces the frequency with which
the individual member of the society
encounter such causes a disturbance on
this via the susceptibility to emotional
disturbance may not be decreased.
It may in fact be increased the
protective cocoon of uniformity in
personal appearance.
Manners and social activity generally
will make small deviations from customer
care increasingly
strange,
exhausted.
The general thesis is sound increasingly
intolerable.
The inevitable small deviations from
customers will bolt increasingly large
and the members of the society finding
themselves tolerating trivial deviations
well.
We'll continue to think of themselves as
socially adapted with that.
The last sentence there,
I mean when he says it a little,
because first it is to read that this
even the slightest difference will be
noticed as large,
but then you're saying that that we're
bearing that there will be born well.
Does that mean that the biggest society
does.
He just means that maybe I'll be able to
tolerate you if your hair is an inch
longer than mine,
and if I can do that,
I will think I'm taller,
but if it's three inches longer,
well,
I said look out.
So what he's basically saying is the
range within which the definition of
tolerance exists will become
increasingly restricted.
So
nonetheless,
society will continue to think of itself
as Tom.
Absolutely right.
Absolutely.
So now what does that have to do with
the great mother,
which was of course the question that I
addressed the quote to,
well,
if have this right,
and other people have made very similar
suggestions,
including you who said that?
This is quite hilarious.
I think he said what is ordinarily
called religion is a substitute to such
an amazing degree that I asked myself
seriously when did this kind of
religion,
which I prefer to call a creed,
may not after all,
have an important function in human
society.
The substitute has the obvious purpose
of replacing immediate experienced by a
choice of suitable symbols,
tricked out with an organized dogma,
and Rachel,
the Catholic Church,
maintains the by her indisputable
authority,
the Protestant church,
if this term is still applicable by
insistence on belief and the evangelical
message,
so long as these principles work,
people are effectively protected against
the media who they just experience.
The notion being that the purpose of dog
culture is protect people from religious
experience now might think,
well,
why does it have to do with him
statement?
Well,
the essence of religious experience
might be regarded as as overwhelming
emotional experience,
and what young is saying is that the
purpose of Dogma
is to protect you from encounter with
the most fundamental emotions and have
points out that culture may protect you
so well.
Then you have no idea what it is that
you're being protected from.
The general thesis of this course is
that the thing that you are protected
from,
it's so terrible that you'll do anything
to maintain the protection even though
under most circumstances you won't even
know that it's there.
The reason I want you to read the great
mothers because it contains a
description of symbols that have been
accumulated in innumerable societies
over thousands of years that have been
created in an attempt to portray the
nature of what is so terrible that you
cannot tolerate it,
and to the degree that art works,
this symbolic representations of the
unknown are effective because most of
those I would say,
fact that what our does,
you know,
if you think,
think about it this way,
that the purpose of culture isn't as
similar to Oregon and that's one way of
looking at it and the processes that
exist around the perimeters of the
Oregon,
so to speak.
Think of it as an island.
It's always expanding.
The processes that work in the middle of
the island aren't the same processes
that work on the edges,
the clothes that you are to the middle,
so to speak.
The more things are absolutely defined
which which is to say that you can
explain them in words.
They very predictable and been given a
rational,
rational underpinnings.
They're explicitly discussable there
semantically formulated,
but around the edges,
x word peculiar activities still takes
place.
That would be the initial stages of the
assimilation process and that's where
fantasy plays a big,
big role because fantasy is the place
where the unknown first transforms
itself into the unknown and while you
could say that people's use of symbols
and that sort of thing,
you know,
artistic productions are their attempt
to make up the unknown.
Something provisionally.
No,
I mean I think that's what art is doing.
It's always working as it,
as the little cow where new information
is being fed.
New cultural information is being fed
into the culture.
That's its purpose.
And there's a book by
no,
there was an address by social units and
the Nobel prize winning addressed,
I think it's called beauty will save the
world,
which is a dusty esky quote.
And this is an argument that social
media makes that link of purpose of,
um,
of higher order culture,
the humanities and the arts on to open a
window into those domains that still
exist as unknown.
And to let some new information in,
you would say,
well,
artistic religious symbols of that sort
function to do that.
Over time they performed their function.
Then they lose their vitality.
So you can't tell what they mean
anymore.
They don't.
They don't intrinsically attract your
attention anymore.
Forget what they mean.
The reason I want you to read the great
mother and to look at the in there so
that
with any luck,
what the people who made those
representations were trying to
communicate will retain.
It's significant so that you can see the
nature of the terror that religious dog,
one culture in general,
which gives everything a uniform
appearance of irregularity.
Why?
That was what that was all directed to
protect us against.
So now it's the purpose of that whole.
And I think if you read it,
it will do it.
What's the title of Associate Address?
Beauty will save the world.
I have the essay in a collection
than I can.
I can show you.
Even if you look at,
look at it this way.
Okay,
so you walk into a museum.
Mrs Happened to me on a number of
locations.
There's all paintings everywhere and
some of them have no emotional
significance at all.
You know,
you might try to
generate some sort artificially,
but a lot of them just don't capture you
now.
And then if you're lucky,
if you're in a good museum,
I suppose whether you know something or
not also makes a difference,
but you'll come across a payday or a
statue that will grab you and the reason
that grabs you,
I think.
So.
It's a visual portrayal.
Um,
then go.
That's a good example of sunflowers.
What van Gogh managers to do is to
present you something that's familiar or
that you think is familiar,
which means something that you've
habituated to,
which means something that you think you
understand,
but he twists it so that the phenomena
now retains that.
The novelty that perhaps it once had
when you first encountered the thing or
in the primeval state,
I suppose would be a symbolic way of
looking at it.
So what the artist's forces you to do,
at least momentarily,
it's to snap out of the or habituated
complacency and to view the object
that's being represented as something
that has not yet lost its sheen of arts
pristine.
It's pristine aspect,
so then you can see what's actually
there instead of looking at your own
memory,
which is what you almost always do when
you look at something and you have very
limited attentional capacity and almost
everything that you encountered,
you see as a representation of that
thing.
Everything that you've explored before,
that's how your brain,
in a sense makes the most use out of its
limited capacity.
You always watch your own memory and a
great artist is someone who can snap you
out of that momentarily to make you see
what's actually there and theoretically
that can give you some insight,
some additional insight into the nature
of the world.
And art in that sense still has a
religious function in their arch.
Originally only had a religious
function.
It's only had a nonreligious function in
the west for maybe 400 years.
So
for the bulk of human history,
art played an explicitly and that's what
it's trying to do.
It's the place where information
is first manifest,
first manifests itself before it becomes
something that's concrete and
candidate.
So anyways,
hopefully if you look at the great
mother,
you'll be able to see these
constructions with the same eyes that
the people who originally made them and
you can tell if that happens because
the objects will stop looking like
foreign cultural artifacts and start
looking like representations of
something.
And it's really.
I think you can really see a shift in
perception if,
if,
if if you,
if you were doing the right thing,
what you want to try to do is to occupy
the territory,
the person who originally constructed
the representation to see what it was
that they were trying to portray.
A lot of these figures,
they took a lot of work.
You know,
you have to be highly motivated to spend
hours or weeks or even years
constructing a representation of
something that you don't really
understand.
You have to put yourself in the position
of those people and see what it was,
what worked it,
and think about what it must have been
that grip them so hard to motivate them
to produce something that has so little
apparent economic value and yet it takes
so much effort,
so it's very.
It's very worthwhile to do that.
The use and abuse of history.
That's the next leg.
It's a very small book.
The reason that I want you to read that
is because it's the only book that I
know of.
It clearly describes the pathological
aspect of culture,
not the pathological aspect of any
particular culture,
but the fact of the culture as a
phenomenon necessarily.
How's it pathological impact or
pathological aspect that's inevitable.
He basically points out that
history is a burden as well as,
uh,
as well as a great advantage.
And to put it simplistically,
I suppose what you might think of is the
fact that if you're going to be a
classical musician,
for example,
the fact that innumerable classical
musicians have lived before you is a
tremendous opportunity because you have
the opportunity to master the skills
they developed and transmitted,
but by the same token,
it's also an incredible impediment to
your own progress because your domain of
competition has become so broad,
you know it only compete for preeminence
and recognition in the present with all
the other people who are trying to
become classical musicians,
but you necessarily pit yourself against
those people who were the absolute best
at that for as long as that particular
activity is being recorded.
So as a consequence,
you're necessarily trivialized in
relationship to the,
to these heroic figure something
the past.
So neat.
You have also added to that by saying
that the great composers of the past
have also limited the president composer
by making the eyes of of everyone around
them used to the,
to the,
to the kinds of stuff that previous one
time at created would expect that.
Yes,
yes.
Certainly whenever I think like I can,
I think you can see minor indications of
this on an ongoing basis in our own
culture.
Like I think one of the things that
mass,
the mass reproduction of music for
example,
has done because this also.
This also occurs with televised events
because the television is even more
accurate.
What television does is make history of
an event as it curves and the fact that
you get the historical perspective on
things as they're instantaneously
occurring I think is very hard on your
own perception of the utility of meaning
of your own life.
It strikes me that increasingly we're in
the position of not presuming that
anything is real unless we see it on
television and that people have devalued
their own personal culture and I mean by
that they're individual culture and
their familial culture in favor of this
global culture which which although it
appears to be ongoing,
is really sort of instant history.
So the thing about a television has,
it'll capture your attention no matter
what.
Someone.
It'll capture your attention instantly,
which basically means that you're
considering the thing that's being
portrayed as more important than
anything that you could be doing at that
present time.
So the how does that.
How's that?
Is that what you mean by history or do
you mean something else?
By checking into history,
meaning taken away,
taken away what people would add to it
or.
I mean what I understand what?
Well,
it's just part of the weight of the.
Like.
The thing about television is that it's
the whole culture,
right in your living room.
You know what?
It's a tremendous.
It competes tremendously for your
attention.
I mean it offers you access
theoretically all these cultural
resources,
but at the same time simultaneously
while you're engaged in getting access
to these resources,
you're not actually living and you're
not producing or creating anything of
your own so that it's a good example of
what Nietzsche is talking about when he
talks about the abusive history.
So wait,
it gets an opportunity because it's
information,
but at the same time it's a tremendous
weight.
So you know,
you see this when you get people sitting
around.
This used to happen to me in graduate
school now and then when people would
sit around and a large chunk of their
childhood memories that are shared
memories were television shows that they
had all watched.
And what that means is that instead of
having individual memories about the
events,
you have transpersonal memories about
the same events that aren't even real.
I think that's another indication of how
it.
Yeah,
it is.
It's very peculiar.
Very peculiar.
Well,
I was thinking that this was more
trivial,
but I was thinking the time
that this has only happened over a span
of 40 years.
Say Rock music is only 40 years old,
but as there was more and more of it,
the likelihood that I'm stations like
these,
all these golden oldies stations popped
up in the eighties and they played like
the music of the sixties and the
seventies.
And what happens is there's a limited
bandwidth of radio and the historical
productions occupy a broader and broader
section of the bandwidth until the new
bands,
so to speak,
are not only competing against all the
other bands who were now,
but all the other bands that have
accumulated over this 40 year period
when nature,
he talks about the weight of history,
the accumulated weight of history.
Well that's a trivial example as I said,
but that's.
It's still something that's happened
over the span of four years.
So it's a burden.
So it's a very short essay that I
thought was the best answer I've ever
encountered on that particular topic.
So nature,
you see the reason I like that,
it's because they need to.
Being an extraordinary burner.
Genius was always cognizant of the fact
that you don't get this,
which is like the protective aspect of
the great father.
That's the thing that renders everything
predictable,
intolerable.
You don't get that.
Then you can get it without also getting
this is that the wise king and the
tyrants are inseparable and there can be
some movement back and forth from one to
the other.
I mean,
it does seem upon occasion all of
culture can turn into something
tyrannical,
but Nancy was pointing out that even in
its most positive guys is the fact that
there is culture constitutes an
impediment to your own success as well
as one of the preconditions of your
success.
You get kind of warped views of that.
This is mostly interesting for those of
you who
are interested in clinical psychology or
psychopathology.
The humanistic branch of psychology
basically took this argument but only
half of it and he said,
well,
because one of their questions was
where?
Where does human evil come from?
Where human suffering,
I suppose it Carl Rogers and Abraham
maslow and probably the foremost
exemplars of humanistic psychology.
They basically made the presupposition
that this is their story.
The individuals intrinsically good and
if you just provide the proper
preconditions,
then everything will turn out positively
to the degree that the individual isn't
good.
It's because society,
which is then cast complicity in the
negative role,
distorts the possibilities of the
individual as he or she matures.
Well,
that's a good story and it's true.
I mean,
it's obviously the case that as you
mature all sorts of arbitrary
limitations and be placed on you,
really arbitrary limitations,
many of which have crushed and distorted
and work your your character in some
matters that might even be unalterable,
but by the same token,
this is also true is that you are an
behave nasty little brood when you were
little and it was the positive aspect of
culture in force on your behavior that
made you even vaguely socially
acceptable.
Now the humanists tend to tell one side
of the story.
This is the thing.
This is another reason why I really like
this,
this diagram because it's a pretty
simplistic diagram,
but the fact that it's a complete story
is very useful and if you know the
complete story,
you know that,
well,
yes,
there's negative aspects of culture,
but they're in separately tied to the
positive aspects and yes,
there are negative aspects of nature or
the unknown,
but there are also positive aspects and
likewise for the individual than it.
If you know that,
if you understand what it means,
then it can stop you from falling sort
of whole heartedly into what I think are
relatively one sided simplistic
ideologies.
Because if someone says,
well,
you know,
all human evil is attributable to the
faults of society.
You can say,
well,
yes,
but you know,
here are all sorts of counterexamples to
that particular claim.
Or if people say,
well,
because this is a common
environmentalist claim,
sort of.
This is kind of funny.
I had another friend in graduate school
who was a German great big guy.
I mean he was a German ancestry and uh,
he,
he was really a nice fellow.
Which meant that in your contact with
him,
you never observed any overt aggression.
And uh,
he told me once he was a left sort of,
he had your typical left leaning liberal
philosophy,
the ideology.
He was environmentally concerned and he
was anti big business and so on and so
forth,
which is all perfectly reasonable.
But he told me once the planet would be
better off if there were no people on
it,
meaning that human beings intrude onto
nature and destroy things and that it
would be better.
But then I thought,
well that's an interesting example,
the collective unconscious,
I suppose,
because
the notion that the notion that the
planet would be better off without
people in it presumes that
nature is something that's all
beneficial.
The pristine and unspoiled nature is all
positive,
so he is dominated by the archetype is
dominated by this architect is thinking
unconsciously.
He thought nature was a French
impressionist landscape.
But then he said,
well,
the planet would be better off without
people on it.
Which meant that if he was given his
free rein of expression,
he would immediately become an exponent.
This part of the great mother and do his
best to,
to decimate everything that he could lay
his hands on.
Yes,
the people than I thought.
I thought it was interesting and in part
given his German cultural ancestry,
because the idea that the planet would
be better off without people on it was
certainly something that motivated the
Nazis.
For example,
so whenever you hear anybody say that,
I mean,
he,
he was no problem because he was in
graduate school,
graduate students at most.
He could recap all according to his
girlfriend and maybe a few friends,
you know,
if you really went into all out.
But uh,
anyways,
I don't understand what the frame of
references is that I'm negative.
Positive,
positive to the individual or is it two
areas are just innately negative or
positive?
I don't understand.
Is the emotional.
I guess it's the emotional
valence of the different domains.
All I'm saying there is that any
phenomena has the capacity to produce
both positive and negative emotions
depending on the context and
interpretation,
sort of an implicit part of it.
I guess it would be in reference to the
individual.
Okay.
So presumes a subject.
So the negative,
the negative aspect.
So the great mother on this side where
the individual is positive,
um,
is,
is seen by the individual is negative.
Oh,
well.
I see what you're saying there is the
positive aspect of culture protects you
from the negative aspect of Don.
No.
Okay.
And here it's that the negative aspect
of culture,
uh,
for bids,
your contact with the positive aspect of
the unknown,
which was your point,
say with regard to the composers,
there are ways that you should conduct
yourself,
which means here's a whole set up
alternative possibilities which you're
forbidden to explore and that's useful
because you won't become afraid,
but it's constricting is restricted to
your potential domain of activity.
And I would say here,
well,
the reason these two are matched is
because it's the negative aspect of the
individual that we'll see later that
heightens the likelihood that culture
will take on a negative or tyrannical
last time.
So I would say for example,
let's take a look at the Nazis.
Now,
one of the things that Nazis were trying
to do,
they have a tight ideology and they were
trying to produce a domain that was very
secure and they were sacrificing people
all the time to construct this
particular domain.
So,
and I would say that,
well,
there's two reasons possibly to,
to
persecute other people.
One is because they're in your way and
you're trying to construct a do a domain
that's secure,
so if you're an explorer,
for example,
when you come across another tribe of
people who don't speak your language,
while as far as you're concerned,
they're barbarians and your job is to
establish your territory,
but then the other reason for first
accusing other people is because you
enjoy it because there's something
pathological about you and I would say
that the cultural movement,
which is to establish new territory
tends to become aligned with individual
pathology and when that happens,
then you get increased likelihood that
when territory is being established that
people will be persecuted.
So people like the Nazis would say,
well,
this is necessary because we want to
establish the third.
Right?
Which is our particular brand of utopia
on earth.
That's their.
That's their justification that they
wear like a uniform so that when they
look at themselves in the mirror and
they can tolerate it,
but really what's going on is that they
really liked to hurt people and they can
use the cultural movement,
which is part of the hero's journey.
In a sense to mask that even to
themselves.
So can you,
can you look at each circle that has
some kind of fortress I guess,
or a castle and yeah,
this is a counselor
negatives.
When you partner likes a track and this
and unlikes whatever repel.
So I mean the positive doesn't let in
the negative.
Negative doesn't end with a positive
with positive lead in the positive and
negative 11.
I think that's a reasonable way of
looking at this could easily be
conceptualized as a castle wall here in
particular with would that out,
you know,
this domain being outside the
individual's surrounded by the culture.
That's,
which is what I was saying with regards
to the great mothers.
You never get to look at this even
because you're so well protected by
this.
You don't even know what's there.
So it's like in the story of Buddha,
Buddha was brought up by his father and
uh,
on just before Buddhist birth,
a sage told his father that he will need
to grow up to be the world's savior or a
political leader.
And his father wanted him to be a
political leader anyways.
So one of the things he did to help
ensure that he would stay in love with
the world so that he occupied that
domain was to erect a wall around him
and to put a paradise that means a
walled city.
By the way,
that's very interesting.
I think to put around Buddha Gautama a
castle wall,
and inside the castle there was nothing
that was sick or old or in any way
diseased because he didn't want to
become conscious to essentially become
self conscious and to abandon the world.
So that's another good.
That's that story.
Has this structure explicitly like the
great father erects the wall around the
individual to protect him or her against
the negative aspect of the unknown.
And that's,
that's.
I mean that's the subject matter for
today's discussion basically.
So okay,
so you're reading use an abusive history
because niche outlines the positive and
the negative aspects of it.
History.
Sorry,
I just wanted to ask you something about
what you said about what your friends
said about the world being better off
without people because that that seems
to be sort of a strange and really
meaningless projection because without
sort of an emperor of a more sizing of
the state of the world because without,
without people,
but world
could not be said to be better or worse
in any way whatsoever beyond completely
meaningless.
Yeah.
Well that's why I
immediately look for turtle alternative
motive,
especially given his ancestry,
which isn't to say that there's anything
peculiar about journalists necessarily
just that it's not far.
We're not far enough away from what
happened in the Second World War for the
reasons for what happened to have
disappeared or changed in any
significant way whatsoever.
It's another reason why trying to work
with this material.
In the introduction of the book,
one of the things I tried to point out
was the fact that we don't know what to
remember about the Holocaust or what to
change in our behavior as a consequence
of its occurrence.
It's only happened not even yesterday
and we're still the same people that we
were.
So when he says that the planet would be
better off without people on it,
then I immediately wonder,
well,
just precisely what does that mean?
Like what's your real motivation?
His motivation is something like there
are
people are tainted intrinsically,
so badly that the only solution to the
problem of their existence and to the
problem they posed to nature.
So to speak,
that below there,
the fact that they are our nature is to
rid the planet of the.
Now you might think that's making a lot
out of an offhand statement,
but the point is that people do act very
often as if they're motivated by
precisely that set of motivations.
So here you've got the identification of
the positive aspect of the individual
with the positive aspect of the unknown.
Because if you're saying that he wants
to destroy somebody who wants to save
nature,
um,
well,
if,
what if one of these reacting against
the,
essentially the negative aspect of the
great father,
which is,
which essentially,
yeah,
but which is composed of all of the,
as you were saying about the
identification of the negative aspect of
it,
of the individual with the,
with the,
uh,
negative aspect of,
of the father.
Then what then what he wants to
eliminate as essentially the negative
aspect of the father.
But the reason you would do that would
be for the sake of the,
of the positive individual and there.
And it seems to me that then,
then to project that on bias in terms of
just you're trying to save the planet,
which is nature.
I think people seem to identify nature
in the positive sense with the positive
in.
Oh,
you,
so you,
you're,
you're making the point essentially that
he was confused in these mythological
precept positions.
Is that.
Well,
um,
possibly.
I don't know.
It just,
it seems to me that,
well,
you know,
like the idea that there is some,
the God that has everything everyone has
has in them.
Um,
I mean,
it seems like if you're saying it seems
to be strange,
strangely paradoxical to say that you
want to,
you want to eliminate the human race,
um,
for the of nature because what
it really seems to me that you're saying
is that you're,
you want to save what is natural and
people.
I mean.
Well,
that's cool.
That's what I,
that's why I was wondering about
confusion.
Presuppositions.
Yeah.
Well,
um,
I don't know.
I don't know where to go exactly any
farther with that particular argument.
I mean,
he had.
Well,
I don't know what else to say about
that.
Have you been saying.
I mean,
can you,
can you say that you liked nature and
also say that you want to help the world
because.
Well,
I mean,
could you be lying in?
He could,
he could.
When he says he wants to save the world,
could you actually say,
I want to kill a bunch of people?
Yes,
absolutely.
Certainly.
Sure.
And then it was,
that's the best excuse for killing a
bunch of people.
It's the one that if you adopt,
makes you tolerable to yourself.
So I suppose it would always be the case
in a sense because if you're saving your
world,
if you're,
I in in terms of what we're talking,
sure,
it's,
it's a logical justification,
which perhaps upon occasion is even
true,
but it's also the kind of justification
that can easily and rapidly be twisted
for your own particular nasty and see.
Because one of the things that's
interesting about war is the fact that
people will commit crimes in the course
of work there that go beyond
the don't actually help the cause of the
war in any particular manner.
And not only that undermine necessarily
the things that,
that person is theoretically fighting
for.
Like one of the things that springs to
my mind is,
uh,
the plan rape of the Muslim women in,
in what used to be Yugoslavia.
And it takes that particularly the
justification that we are just
establishing our own secure territory is
not sufficient to motivate the planning
of that kind of event.
You need some other little bent twist to
come up with something that,
uh,
that it brilliantly cruel.
And anyways,
I'm discussing this in part as a,
what would you call a precursor to the
whole last section of this particular
course because one of the things we're
going to discuss in detail is the nature
of that additional twisted motivation.
We haven't talked anything about this at
all.
Yeah.
So yeah.
Wait,
so I'm trying to understand what you
just said is the only way that you can,
you can justify rape is not only to,
for the war to be a warring over land
but also over this objective territory.
Well,
I would think if you,
if you,
if whole land women were to be raped,
that would.
I mean it obviously affects
it.
It brings down the morale of the women
that were raped and also the community,
the community because when that
happened.
So it's not really a material gain when
but also an emotional.
Well,
I would,
I would say under most conditions it
would be the reverse because I think
like if you want to defeat someone,
I think anything you can do to them
that's gratuitously cruel likely only
heightens their will to resist.
So I think it works as if it actually
would work as something
counterproductive.
So anyways,
I want to leave this because we'll get
back to this in detail later in the
course.
This is,
like I said,
this is just sort of a preview and it
says I want to get your mind thinking
about this other.
Because the law,
one of the things you see we don't take
into account,
and this is true in general psychology I
think is we have a hard time coming to
terms with more complex base
motivations.
Like we don't.
We're not very good at conceptualizing
things like a cleaning fee undertaken
for aesthetic purposes.
So we can't really come to grips with
that.
Like even when we talk about antisocial
personalities,
for example,
we tend to.
We don't tend to think about it in terms
of some sort of.
All the evil is being taken out of the
personality.
It's something that's just a matter of,
uh,
say heightened approach systems and
reduced response to anxiety and so on.
There's a whole set of complex
motivations were not very good at like
the desire to kill things to hurt
things.
We don't know how to deal with that or
how they conceptualize it.
Anyway.
So we're going to talk about that,
but there's also taken out of that also,
right?
The more complex positive,
the complex positive,
like maybe their desire to learn from
pushing the borders.
Possibly.
Yeah.
Okay.
So the structure of scientific
revolutions,
I want you to read that because what
killing discovered with regards to
scientific revolutions,
I think is just just get beyond good and
evil.
Oh yes,
I did.
Okay.
Beyond good and evil,
I would like you to read because me and
she wrote it after Western culture had
moved into an intervening period of
chaos as a consequence of the loss of
its religious foundations.
And so you could say that when there's,
you know,
the bouncing ball diagram,
well,
when Western culture,
the religious presuppositions of western
culture will were shattered.
There was an intervening period of time
where morality as such had unspecified,
an unspecified reason for being a niche.
He was trying to explore the nature of
what used to be taken for granted,
which was the existence of the religious
structure and the possibilities for
reconstructing an alternative morality.
I suppose that would be rationally,
irrationally comprehensive.
I guess the reason I want you to read
beyond good and evil war particularly
those because reading that should do to
you.
It's like an initiation ritual,
I guess in a sense that's intellectually
produced because nature,
he said himself,
he philosophize with a hammer.
His point was to break down
presuppositions.
That's what he wanted to do for a
defined end.
He wanted to release the will power,
I suppose,
or to make people aware of it.
And I would say what the will,
the will to power could be most
accurately conceptualized in terms of
thing that allows people to continue
continually erect structures of nod,
break them down and redirect them.
I think that's.
That's what nature striving.
Yeah.
I mean it's difficult to see what he was
driving out.
So there'd be lots of debate about that.
But beyond good and evil is,
is useful to read for a number of
reasons.
First of all,
you'll never find another book,
I think in your whole life.
That's so unfair.
It's so remarkable.
Brilliant Nature said that he wanted to
write in a sentence what other people
could not write in a book.
And I think that he accomplished that,
particularly with beyond good and evil.
Every sentence is a thought and most of
the thoughts are brilliant and there are
many books that have one thought in them
and not even such a good thought.
So it's also pretty useful from a
stylistic perspective because nature was
a master,
a literary master and reading him can
help clear up your thinking.
She's amazingly clear thinker.
So anyways,
so those are the reasons for.
He's also questioning,
see nature,
you said that he was the first
philosopher who didn't set out a
priority to prove that a particular
morality that already existed was true.
Like Nisha said,
look up to me.
Every western philosopher has worked
within an established moral system and
only attempted to justify it even though
they didn't know that's what they were
doing.
He thought that he was the first
philosopher in history who is capable of
saying of seeing that alternative
realities existed everywhere and that's
the fact of morality had become a
problem.
Why is the morality not which morality
is right even or that are particular?
Morality isn't necessarily right,
but why is the morality and Ken,
they're justifiably the morality?
Is there any reason for presuming that
the question,
what is good and what is evil is even
worth asking or answering or has any
reasonable answer?
Those are all questions he was
attempting to address because Nietzsche
believed,
if you knock the god out of a religious
system,
which is a moral system that the entire
moral system,
therefore it no longer has any reason to
exist,
and if it has no reason to exist,
it will disappear.
Quite take hundreds of years,
but it will disappear,
and that's why he said God is dead and
we have killed him.
He also said to finish that phrase off,
that we will have a difficult time
finding enough water to wash away all
the blood,
which was his prophecy for the 20th
century and the part of the quote that
many people do not,
don't realize.
Photos.
The first part,
he was attempting to address the
problem.
If we lost our religious belief,
so now what did we do for morality?
So it's worth it's worth reading for a
number of reasons.
The structure of scientific revolutions,
Thomas Kuhn,
discovered,
don't be.
Don't mean to imply by that,
that before when we were in western
society had thought there was any less
fortunate.
Yeah,
well that's a complicated question
because part of it's technical
technologically technologically relate.
Yeah.
Would that be
right?
No Way.
I don't mean to imply that I don't think
probably he meant to imply it either,
but his point I think was more
particularly that
the demise of fixed religious systems
would necessarily mean that the
conflicts of the 20th century would be
ideologically motivated,
specifically ideologically motivated as
annuity ologies rose up to try to occupy
the territory.
That previous ideology or religion
really hasn't been any allergy because
most of them,
most of our religion is implicit and
most of the ideologies exploits it.
I think because someone actually wrote
it down,
call it Karma isn't,
for example,
is more likely to a sense more like a
scientific system because all the
presuppositions are actually
are actually explicit,
so I think there's some reason for
distinguishing niche.
You thought,
well these new ideologies would
necessarily rise up to who occupied the
position of ideology and that we'd see
more fair on a grand scale in Europe as
a consequence of that.
So no,
because it's not reasonable to say that.
It's hard to say know because people
compare what Stalin did,
for example,
in the name of videology,
to what the Catholic Church didn't,
Spain during the period of the
inquisition.
The inquisition was nowhere near as
horrifying as the Stalinist purges,
but it's difficult to tell if that's
because the motivation different or
because by the time of stolen the
technology for implementing inquisition
like procedures were so far advanced,
so
solzhenitsyn believed the Stalinist
purges were worse than anything that had
happened in Russia,
his previous history under the czar and
worse than this,
the inquisition as well,
but again,
there's this complicating technology,
so I don't know what to say about that.
Precisely.
I don't think people have probably
changed that much,
so have the people who ran the Spanish
inquisition had access to the
technology,
the product just this horrible.
Okay.
For the structure of scientific
revolutions,
Kuhn
couldn't basically attempts to
demonstrate that this bouncing ball
diagram also applies in the scientific
domain.
That's not exactly right.
He attempted to say that a process like
this applied in the scientific domain
without necessarily considering the fact
that it might characterize all cognitive
revolutions,
including those that operate in the
domain of morality.
The reason I want you to read this book
is because one of the risks of the
approach that I take in this class is
over reliance on a few sources.
I tend to rely heavily on you,
for example,
and that's partly because they're the
only people that I know who actually
deal with this material.
So I don't think it's so much narrower
as just lack of options.
But I wanted you to read Kuhn because
you've.
Well that way you can.
That's a book that was very well
received.
They made become world famous.
It was published in I think 1960 in
1962.
Um,
I want you to see for yourself that
these sorts of ideas appear relevant in
other fields and have been discovered by
other people who are working from
entirely different,
from entirely different set of
presuppositions.
And also because you have such a
terrible academic reputation,
which I can on and on actually
understanding to,
to allow you to see for yourself that an
idea that made kill and world famous and
in 1960 was positive 30 or 40 years
earlier by you on a much broader scale
and was as far as I can tell,
more or less completely overlooked.
I don't know why that is.
Anyways,
the devils.
Okay.
The Devil's paradise lost notes from the
underground and the Gulag archipelago.
I'll make a unit and the unit is a
discussion of the negative aspect of the
individual paradise lost.
This is the first time I've used this
book in this course.
Paradise lost is the story of the fall
of the devil from having now what he
tried to do while he tried to do two
things,
he said he was trying to justify the
ways of God to man,
which is an amazingly ambitious project.
No,
it's amazing that someone would take it
upon themselves to too seriously conduct
an enterprise like that.
But also what he did was there's a kind
of a,
okay,
remember I used the example and you say,
if you want it to think about what art
and mythology does with relationship to
the construction of knowledge that you
might think that if you think of culture
as an island and the processes around
the edge of the island being
qualitatively different from those in
the Middle Myth and art sort of
circulate around outside,
say as information goes more towards the
center,
tends to give,
take more on the shape of Dogma or
codified knowledge,
and on the outside it's less,
it's more amorphous and it seems to be
contained more an image that's,
that's my impression anyways.
Last verbal,
more image.
The farther out it isn't.
Our at the farthest reaches its still
behavior.
It's in ritual and seemed invitation.
Don't even really have an image of it
yet.
You just acted out.
Not only can you not talk about it,
you can't form an accurate image of it,
but you can still act about.
But anyways,
what Milton did was to collect a myth
that have formed around the central core
of Christianity.
And to give it a more or less formal
structure and the math is the notion
that there is a rebellion in heaven and
that the devil fell.
Who was God's highest angel?
One of his two sons.
I guess one.
The other one being Christ say to be the
oldest son rebelled against God in an
attempt to occupy this position and was
cast into hell.
Oh,
it's an interesting.
It's a story that has always running
around in my mind for some peculiar
reason.
Lucifer means light,
bringer,
and Lucifer is the agent of
consciousness,
even in genesis.
As far as that,
that's my particular take on it anyway.
As Lucifer is the serpent who gives both
eve and Adam,
the apple that makes them self
conscious.
He brings them to the light and the
Bible represents that as a catastrophe.
Obviously people get thrown out of
paradise,
but there's some split.
There was apparently,
according to young,
there's even split in the Medieval
Christianity,
the the absolute negative quality of
that particular event because it was
also regarded as a fortunate error
because the fact that Adam and Eve got
kicked out of paradise provided the
precondition for the necessary
appearance of Christ who is a savior or
hero.
So anyways,
I'm interested.
Look,
Christianity took the discussion at the
devil and his nature farther than any
other form of religion has ever taken.
The discussion of of evil could say that
for us to conceptualize,
say as a culture,
we have been trying to abstract out from
our general behaviors,
the pattern that characterized as evil
ever since we attempted to map who we
were has a conscious endeavor.
Which is to say that we've taken 10 tens
of thousands of years to try to come to
grips with the essential nature of the
behavioral pattern,
their attitude pattern that characterize
as evil.
You know,
we obviously still don't have a very
good verbal description of what that
means because you can't just go up to
your neighbor and say,
you know,
spoke me off a paragraph or two that
will define the boundaries of behavior
that would generally be recognized as
evil.
We don't know that you say.
You could say,
well,
I knew it when I see it,
which means that it's still kind of
implicit knowledge.
I would say that the idea of the devil
seemed to have derived from zero astrium
religion.
There's a garden zoroastrianism named
her a Mazda and he has two sons whose
names escape me.
That was the first religion,
and by the way,
those are osteons also believed that the
universe was engaged in an internal
battle between the forces of good and
evil and that they were basically
balanced,
which Christianity didn't,
didn't exactly dog that.
It's referring to this as well.
The battle between good neat.
Anyways,
Christianity's things the end,
he started fuel from the self is there,
thereby leaving it to be repressed and.
Well,
it's something.
Yeah,
it's something that's.
Well,
the thing you know,
there's a lot of sense in this story.
What about original?
Well,
yes,
but it wasn't a young.
One of the things that young find out
was that the triumvirate of that the
trinity are there.
That is,
that is God is really a fraternity.
The debt and the devil attacks attempts
to eliminate the evil from from the
individual.
Yeah.
Well that was something that you can
have a particular moment about boat,
about Christianity with because he
thought that he thought exactly what
Christianity tended to view evil as the
absence of God,
whereas young tended to view it as a,
as an actual presence in and of itself,
something that was complex enough and
solid enough so to speak,
that you couldn't just account for it by
the absence of something good and that
was a,
I suppose in medieval times that would
be needed as a remarkably heretical
state.
So that was humans particular take on
it,
but there are good reasons for believing
the opposite to the to to believe that
evil can be understood as the absence of
good.
That's a real logical argument to.
I don't think it's one that you'll give
enough credence to that is that it's
still your presentation is what he
thought.
Anyways,
let's get back to this myth
Lucifer's associated with rationality in
Christian mythology,
and the reason I want you to read
paradise lost is because I think what
paradise lost is about,
and this is,
I don't know,
this is pure speculation on my part,
is certainly about something that we
know people have been working on
building that myth for a long,
long,
long time.
It's about something but what it's
about,
and I doubt very much if it's a
description of empirical reality.
So it's about something else and what
that meant says is that the highest
angel in God's kingdom,
which I would view as something as a
description of an interest psychic
state,
the place where there are spirit,
so to speak,
attempted to you serve God's position
which is characterized by omnipotent,
omniscient,
omnipotent,
and uh,
it was pretty.
The other one is three cardinal
attributes of God should omniscience,
omnipotence,
omnipresence,
right?
Said,
I can occupy the position of God
instantly.
He's inhale.
Now,
I think what that means,
and this is something that from northrop
prior also commented on was the
say,
if you think of the development of
rationality,
Cuban rationality,
which is one of the things that
necessarily distinguishes us from the
animals in which western culture has put
more stress on than any other culture.
I think that can be reasonably portrayed
from the mythological perspective as the
highest angel in God's heavenly kingdom,
so to speak.
Think about that as the description of
an inter psychic hierarchy.
What that says,
that what that says is that if
rationality construct something and then
attempts to make of it a god,
instantly everything around it will turn
into something that resembles hail 10.
It's a story about.
I think it's a story about the dangers
of authoritarian presumption,
so I want you to read it in the context
of these other works and you can make
your own judgment about that.
Which is to say,
look,
all it is is to say this.
If you construct the system of belief
with your rational faculties and then
make up that system,
something that has all the attributes of
God,
then what will necessarily happen
because you're completely opaque to any
anomalous information,
is that within a brief span of time,
everything around you will turn into a
wasteland and also that all you have to
do to get out of it is admitting that
you're wrong,
which is one of the things that happens
to milk Satan by the way,
all he has to do to get out of where he
is is admit that he was wrong.
That's it,
but he won't do that.
So I would rather I'd rather rule
inhaled and serve in heaven and I,
I think from my perspective as a
clinical psychologist,
that that's the most accurate
representation of neurotic personality
that I've ever encountered.
So that's exactly the situation.
Just like you're doing something that
follows up your life,
you'd rather do that than change
specifically as you because you're the
master of it.
That's right.
It's knowing what we know how that
works.
It's unknown territory,
isn't it?
Because you don't have to.
You don't have to go through this
process,
for example,
to stay there.
It might be miserable and it's gonna get
worse all the time and it will get as
bad as it can possibly be.
Oh,
you have to do.
To get rid of it is to pause that.
If you stepped outside of it's something
good might happen,
but you won't do that.
So is that what you mean when you talk
about Communist Roger?
Yes,
absolutely.
That's an idea.
That's exactly it.
If you think of that though,
it's difficult within the domains of
rationality during depression,
ality.
Yeah,
way.
Well,
that's not necessarily the case level.
I'll give you right away.
We're talking about the relative
importance of phenomena.
So let's let's look at it this way.
Say what your rationality does this help
you make sense of phenomena that you
encountered,
but it is not necessarily the thing that
propels you forward to the place where
you'll find something to make sense out
of.
I would say that so I would say that
your rationality is doing a proper job,
which means that it's in the right place
in the hierarchy values.
If it's always serving the tendency to
go out and make order out of chaos.
Now if you.
That's not rationality,
that's something else.
That's the thing that makes rationality
useful.
Right?
But if your rationality and then it sort
of follows,
but you wouldn't understand this,
you wouldn't necessarily like it.
That's right.
Well,
you don't necessarily want the
subordinate position.
It's something that's very relevant to
western culture because I believe this
is the case.
I hope this is true.
I believe that after the French
revolution,
one of the first things that happened
was the erection of a statue to the
goddess of reason in Notre Dame
cathedral.
Does anybody know if that's true?
I think that was one of the immediate
post revolutionary acts,
but it's very.
It's very symbolic.
I think because the French Revolution
was one of the first extra religious
movements in western culture understands
the attempt to put reason up on the
highest pedestal and there's a problem
with that.
And that's the problem that Milton,
I think was wrestling with and said,
well,
yeah,
you know,
rationalities a good master,
good servant,
but it's a terrible master.
So then the question is what's supposed
to be the master?
Now,
the thing that's interesting about this
is there's,
there's a line of mythology and
Christianity that sort of points out
that this is vague again and there's no
canonical basis board as far as I know,
but the,
uh,
that the,
that Satan was the gods,
oldest son who was passed over in favor
of the youngest son who was Christ.
And that's a common mythological theme
by the way,
that the passing over of the older and
wiser son and in favor of the younger
and more questionable son,
that's part of the,
that's part of the mythology,
the trickster.
But anyways,
the point is here is that rationality.
It's supposed to serve the
as opposed to certainly hero and not to
constrain it.
So you can say it's supposed to be
subordinate,
supposed to be a subordinate process,
and as soon as it's known as supportive
process,
which means as soon as it says,
what I have created is everything that's
necessary,
then it then it.
While that's tantamount to this
revolution in heaven,
this is my spot.
No,
no,
no.
That's,
that's a really good observation because
star trek is pure mythology to boldly go
where no man has ever gone,
no one now,
but that's.
That's right,
because it's a well constructed and
spock is subordinate to the
irrationalities of the human beings.
That's right,
and the drive and the drive to explore.
Right.
Great.
Very Fun.
They also has pointed ears and have a
of
data,
right?
Right.
Rationale,
rationale,
all knowing,
all knowing is the big thing as far as
I'm concerned with regards to radiology,
because that's what an ideology does,
right?
If you're an authoritarian,
although you.
Sorry,
go ahead.
Talking about
religion might be trying to tell about
his or her place within a community.
I'm trying to lead into that in today's
discussion,
and this is all sort of preliminary
material,
but most of the last half of the course
talks about this,
this relationship,
which is what you're trying.
What's the.
What's the proper balance between the
individual and that culture?
Is the idea that religion is supposed to
liberate the individual.
How.
Okay.
Given that line of reasoning,
what,
what would you use as the definition of
self?
The Ego in another words that that
everything is within my own self.
Everything I see and what's real,
what I see is real.
What you may see is not necessarily
right because I'm operating within
myself.
The idea of liberation from the prisons.
I mean that would.
I think in part
the problem is is that there's two
aspects to the systems as a general
rule,
there's the aspect that socializes and
then there's the aspect that attempts to
transcend the consequences of
socialization and they tend to work at
cross purposes.
That's why one of the stories you'll
read later in the manuscript is
edited it down.
Dostoevsky story,
the grand inquisitor and then the grand
inquisitor.
Christ comes back to Earth and he runs
into the inquisitive who says,
who in prisons prison immediately we're
going to kill you.
You established this,
but now that it's here,
you shouldn't come back to mess it up.
Fine.
The next day when he was supposed to
kill him,
he lets him go out the back door.
Well,
that's regarded as sort of as the
pinnacle of Dostoyevsky's literary
achievement.
A particular story,
and it is a brilliant story because it
basically says that,
well,
and this is
mostly with regards to the Catholic
church,
that religion necessarily has to impose
a structure.
It has to because if there's no
structure,
there's no protection,
but in order to maintain that structure,
it has to allow the process that creates
it in order to exist,
at least to the degree that it can
continue to update the structure and
that's like.
That's exactly dead on.
Relevant to your question with regards
to the proper role of the relationship,
proper role of the individual with
regards to culture.
It's the same relationship that the
Pharaoh,
how do you need you to society.
You're supposed to embody the culture
and I would think in part the notion of
the prison of the self is partly the
idea that you embodied the culture which
is that you swallowed the particular
morality and the ways and the means that
your culture says to act,
but then there's this other part which
says,
yeah,
you are that endure necessarily that,
but you're also the thing that created
that and the thing that can update it.
When when necessary,
you also swallowed religion,
which creates,
and I'm not necessarily sure that
religion was free.
No Man from the south because it creates
a suffolk.
Well,
it depends.
It depends.
I mean it because you have to send.
Okay.
This leads in directly to what we were
going to decide what we were going to
discuss today because I,
I,
I titled the Chapter That We're
discussing today apprenticeship that
inculturation and that has to do with
the adoption of a shared map and so the
issue is going to look at this
particular diagram.
I want to read you something again.
I'll get to this one sec.
I just wanted to finish going through
these books.
The last three books have to do with
alchemy and they ultimately is a
discussion.
Humans writing something with me anyways
or discussion of a collection of 2000
years of symbols.
The yellow thought illustrated that
process,
which is the process of radical re
adaptation.
So
I want to read you something for me.
It's kind of long,
but I want you to listen to it
carefully.
This is from the navel and if you want,
if you listened to this,
then you'll also know why I want you to
read beyond good and evil because the
whole book is like this,
not just this particular.
Every morality is as opposed to letting
oneself go,
a bit of tyranny against nature also
against reason,
but this in itself is no objection as
long as we do have some other morality
which permits us to decree that every
kind of tyranny and unreasonable is
impermissible
what is essential and didn't ask to
mobile in every morality because
they've.
It constitutes a long compulsion
to understand stoicism or puritanism.
One should recall the compulsion or
whichever language so far has achieved
strength and freedom.
The metrical compulsion of rhyme and
rhythm.
Okay,
so what Nietzsche is trying to say,
there's
that there's a necessary relationship
between morality and slavery.
To adopt any particular viewpoint means
to exclude all other viewpoints,
but also that having done so,
having adopted one limited viewpoint
means the possibility to develop all
sorts of skills that you might not
otherwise be able to develop.
So it uses the metaphor.
Poetry says,
look what a poet does to produce poetry
and to develop the language is to put
way more constraint on his or her domain
of action than is normally the case and
paradoxically,
as a consequence of applying this
constraint,
something is created instead of just
being repressed.
So you say you don't have to only allow
yourself to write in rhyme and rhythm.
It's much more difficult to do that
which you might say would constitute a
barrier to achievement,
but Nietzsche is pointing out that it is
in fact the position of those
constraints that constitutes the
precondition for freedom.
So he's making a strange,
strange claim that under in some
contexts of interpretation,
slavery as a necessary precondition for
freedom go.
Then the question is,
you better understand the context in
which that's true and the context in
which that's not great and we'll but
we'll get to that later.
How much trouble the poets and orators
of all peoples have taken,
not accepting a few prose writers today
and who's he are there dwells in
exhaustible conscience for the sake of
some foolishness as utilitarian adults
say,
feeling smart,
submitted abjectly to capricious laws as
anarchists,
say,
feeling free or even free spirited,
but the curious fact is that all there
is or has it been on earth of freedom,
subtlety,
boldness,
dance and masterly.
Sharing this weather in thought itself
or in government or in the rhetoric and
persuasion in the arts,
just as an ethics has developed only
owing to the tyranny of such capricious
laws.
Every artist knows how far from any
feeling of letting himself go.
His most natural state is the free
ordering,
placing,
disposing,
giving form in the moment of inspiration
and how strictly and suddenly he obeys
thousand fold laws precisely then laws
that precisely on account of their
hardness and determination defy all
formulation through concepts.
Even the firmest concept is compared
with them not free of fluctuation,
multiplicity,
and then,
but the other thing that needs she's
pointing out there,
and this is an example of how,
how decades of thought that are still to
come are embedded in his sentences.
Law,
is that precisely on account of their
hardness and determination,
defy all formulation through concepts.
He's saying,
well,
when you were free as an artist,
your acting according to precepts that
are inviolable,
that are so archaic that you can't even
say what they are.
They're still implicit,
still implicit,
right?
They're still procedural.
What is essential in heaven and earth
seems to be to say once again that there
should be obedience over a long period
of time and in a single direction given
that something worthwhile always
develops and has developed for whose
sake it is worthwhile to live on earth.
For example,
virtue art,
music,
dance reason,
spirituality,
something transfiguring,
subtle Nad and divine.
The long unfreedom of the spirit.
The mistrustful constraint in the
communicability of thoughts.
The disciplined thinkers imposed on
themselves to think within the
directions laid down by a church or a
court or under era's Tutelian
presuppositions,
the long spiritual will to interpret all
events under a Christian Schema and to
rediscover and justify the Christian God
and every accident.
All of this,
however,
forced capricious hard,
gruesome and anti rash has shown itself
to be the means through which the
European spirit has been trained to
strength,
ruthless curiosity and subtle mobility,
although admittedly in the process and
irreplaceable amount of strength and
spirit had to be crushed,
stifled in the room
that for thousands of years of European
thinkers thought merely in order to
prove something
today.
Conversely,
we suspect everything or who wants to
prove something,
that the conclusions that aren't to be
the result of the most rigorous
reflections were always settled from the
start,
just as it use to be with Asiatic
astrology and still is today with the
innocuous Christian moral interpretation
of our most intimate personal
experiences.
This tyranny,
this Capris,
this rigorous and grandiose stupidity
because educated the spirit.
Slavery is as it seems,
both in the cruder and in the more
subtle sense,
the indispensable means of spiritual
discipline and cultivation to consider
any more,
lot with this in mind,
what there is in it of nature,
teaches hatred of just letting go of any
all to great freedom and implants,
the need for limited horizons and the
nearest tasks,
teaching the narrowing of perspective,
and that's in a certain sense,
stupidity.
As a condition of life and growth,
you shall obey someone in for a long
time or else you will perish and lose
the last respect for yourself.
This appears to me to be the categorical
imperative of nature,
which is not addressed to the
individual,
but to people's races,
ages and classes above all,
to the whole human animal to ma'am.
Brilliant.
That's a brilliant page as far as I'm
concerned.
What's he saying in your question?
What's the proper relationship with
individual in culture with regards to
you say,
well,
what's what?
I wrote this,
this diagram on the board here.
The unknown is both negative and
positive
and the culture is both negative and
positive.
Say you have to have a culture
because the culture brings
predictability to the objects that you
encounter and to all of your
interpersonal interactions.
You have to have that because that in
its absence,
everything is so chaotic that you cannot
actually exist.
That's the literal,
the literal truth.
Your culture regulates your emotions.
You can't just give it up,
but if someone comes along with a
different idea and that different idea,
if you accepted it would upset your
whole culture.
Well,
you can't just accept that idea,
but the alternative to accepting it
often seems to be to attempt to destroy
the person who brings the new
information.
And the problem with that is that now
we're so heavily armed that if one camp
attempts to destroy the other camp,
the overwhelming likelihood is the both
will disappear.
So on the one hand you can't just get
rid of your culture because someone else
comes along and says,
that's not the way to do things,
but you can't do what we've always done
in the past either which has have a war
about it and said,
well,
who's going to rule what territory?
So then the question is,
well,
given those two options,
as theoretically the only two options,
and then both the both the outcomes of
those two options or negative well,
what's left to do well,
that's a real difficult question.
That's a paradox as far as I'm
concerned.
Well,
this diagram has speaks to that to some
degree,
say
nature is pointing out that in order to
be able to do anything,
you have to restrict what it is that
you're going to do to a narrow domain.
This is the notion of an apprenticeship.
So if you want to become,
let's say a classical pianists,
would they say to become a classical
pianist,
you need 20,000 hours of practice before
the age of 18 to become a concert.
That's assuming you have the,
you know,
the innate ability,
which basically means if you have to
exclude from your life any number of
things that would have occupied those
$20,000 alternatively,
and that you have to subjugate all of
your diverse individuality to this
extraordinarily narrow range of,
of action.
But the theory is that having
voluntarily subjugating yourself to a
set of arbitrary and fixed rules,
because the rules that make up music are
in many ways arbitrary and fixed,
that if you master that territory,
then you'll come out the other side with
all of those skills at your disposal and
then with the capacity to do something
that actually constitutes free to have
with them.
So the notion of the apprenticeship is
the long sub voluntary subjugation of
the spirit followed by the capacity to
create a masterpiece.
You know the word masterpiece
that signifies the end of an
apprenticeship right now.
It's even though I suppose where the
master's degree came from,
is that a masterpiece indicates that you
are now free from the tyranny of the
person to whom you were bound.
It means that you've absorbed everything
they know,
plus you've added to what they knew and
transmitted to you.
Something that's uniquely yours that
justifies the entire subjugation.
Well,
that's that for me,
that seems to be the way out the of this
cultural paradox because
that's an apprenticeship model of
adolescence.
I think that group identity is
the construction and strengthening of
group identity is the appropriate
developmental stage for adolescents that
it has to be gone through and this gets
rid of some of.
I think some of the more annoying
aspects of standard humanistic
psychology says you have to accept as a
precondition that subjugate yourself to
a set of rules that a lot of what you
are is going to not be developed in the
process because you always sacrifice
possibility for actuality if you pursue
any actuality,
but the hope is that you'll come out the
other side with whatever is used still
in tact and it seems to me that.
Well that gives you the benefits of both
situations.
If you say the purpose of culture is to
predict,
protect the individual who's no longer a
child from the negative aspect of the
unknown.
Say children are dependent on their,
on their mother,
so to speak.
Initially
as they grow,
they start to
encounter problems in living that their
mother can no longer solve.
Example hundred.
Both conditions like in our culture.
If you're a male and you're 14 and your
brother is still trying to solve the
problem of finding someone to date for
you,
something seriously has gone wrong
because she's attempting to extend her
domain of protection past it's logical
bounce,
which is to say the psychoanalysts used
to refer to that as the necessary
failure of the mother.
Anyways.
The point is is that as you grow up,
life starts to present to you problems
that weren't there to begin with,
that your other campaign and what moves
in fill the gap before you're fully
mature is is the processes associated
with group identification.
So it's like.
I think it's a bridging bridging
mechanism.
I think the problem that we face as a
race in a sense is that we're stuck at
an adolescent level of of adaptation is
that people even still view the
identification with the culture,
which is essentially the adoption of a
patriotic stance.
That's when we're looking at it as the
highest level of possible obtained
insurance people never individually.
Well,
that's
rarely enough.
So that being stuck at the level of
cultural identification still poses a
major constant threat to her poses a
constant threat.
So not a blanket statement,
obviously,
right?
Not a blanket statement because.
But I guess the.
I guess the idea of perhaps is that well
at least that something beyond mere
adequate group identification might
realistically be posited as an ideal
without,
without necessarily undermining the idea
that group identification as a
developmental stage is absolutely
necessary and that it has to be gone
through.
Like I mean you see people who,
who never made the transition to group
identity,
which means that they remain dependent
on their mother.
That's A.
There's a whole category of personality
disorder for that.
That's dependent personality disorder.
They don't even make the first
transition.
People who get through the group
identification process,
I think very often are those who
actually mastered it.
So they have gone through an
apprenticeship,
which means they've allowed themselves
to be subjugated to the group identity
and have absorbed all the discipline and
possibility that that subjugation
subjugation allows me to send you.
Some people do
manage to reach to go beyond that stage
without having very much group
identification
managed to reach the estate reach
individuation without going through a
great deal.
Okay.
Can you think of an example of that?
Because I'm not convinced that that's
the case.
I think that these.
I think that this is an invariant
developmental stage that you can make
the.
I don't think you can make the lead on
and I shouldn't say never,
but I don't think that under most
circumstances you can make the leap from
childhood to adulthood without this
intervening inculturation,
which is mostly group foster because
it's then that you learn,
for example,
as an adolescent,
that's when you learn how to cope with
people in groups and how to and how to
to act as the responsible member of the
culture.
Say once you've got that skill,
then you can go beyond it,
but if you don't have it,
well it seems to me that that provides a
pretty vicious impediment to your
continued progress or do you think think
could you get them at
more or less at the same time?
I mean,
I'm someone who is not particularly
socially capable until they,
until they become self capable and I
think,
I mean I think most,
most kids go from there go from being
children to being members of a group and
then if they're lucky they move beyond
that.
But uh,
what about people who go from go from
children to being,
to being essentially sort of doing
nothing and then building,
doing both at the same time?
I mean because sometimes if you have,
if you have a little enough social
ability you can,
you can be very
vulnerable or are outcast from the,
from the sort of group situation but at
the end.
But at the same time there are people
who are in that situation and we'll also
who have a fair amount of self
competence but,
but no social competence.
Do you see what I.
well,
I was thinking about about possible
exceptions to this.
I guess I would say perhaps that if
someone is popped out of the group,
I identification game because they're
pursuing an interest that's unique to
them.
That it's possible that the continued
development of the interest might lead
to to to a proper establishment of an
adult as an adult,
but I would also say that it's
inappropriate to presume that group
identification necessarily mean
something that happens at the normal
level of adolescent behavior,
which is.
I'm not saying necessarily that to make
the gap,
to make the jump from childhood to
adulthood,
it's necessarily to associate with a
gang of peers like in this a sort of
classic adolescent mode.
I would also say for example,
that if you're interested in something
like say you're really good at the
violin,
that might be an example.
If you have a particular talent,
your peer group then becomes all those
people who've had that talent in the
past who's process of adaptation you're
imitating and mimicking to develop your
skills to move towards the point where
you're going to be an individual in your
old.
Right?
So for us,
I mean this is especially true for
people who are,
who are abstractly capable.
Your peer reference group might be the
group that you find in books because
that's where the group identity has been
abstracted into ideas.
It doesn't necessarily like,
especially in a culture as complex as
ours,
there are peer groups who you can
identify with at every level of
functional analysis.
There are groups that are based purely
on a purely on ideas.
There are groups that are based more
explicitly on shared patterns of
activity,
so.
But I would still say that to get from
the point of being a child to the point
of being an adult,
there has to be this intermediate
intermediary process.
I think culturation you can choose,
you can pick and choose what that's
going to be,
but you need a framework like say,
so
if you.
If you were operating,
if you're someone who is capable enough
in something,
the semantic,
the main may never make it back to
procedures essentially,
which is.
Well,
I think that would also be a mistake as
a general rule,
but.
Right,
but it.
But it can happen.
Yeah,
I think it does.
Well,
what you said about books,
you have to be a representation of that.
Is that some mean someone who's maybe
maybe socially uncomfortable,
but I don't really use it reads a great
deal when you were saying that they're
essentially getting
sure.
Sure,
of course they are.
It's just the thing.
The group they're identifying with his
speed abstracted into into some maybe
their peer group may be people who are
mostly dead who live only in books,
which is not necessarily such a bad peer
reference group.
Depends on your.
Although I would also say that the
inability to deal with the living so to
speak sooner or later is going to
constitute it is likely going to
constitute a problem.
I mean it might not be a fatal error,
but it's still going to be a problem and
even somebody who was as a.
What would you say,
socially isolated as Nietzsche,
especially in the latest part of his
life later part of his life.
He still wrote,
I mean the desire to be part of the
community.
It's very paramount even among people
who are very individualistic and it's
also the case that the hero is not the
person who discovers the goal,
gets the gold from the dragon and then
wanders off up into the hill.
The hero is the person who gets the gold
and then it goes back to the community
so that that presupposes the capacity to
make the knowledge that's been gathered
on the individual route,
accessible to the community and the
skills that allow that to occur.
So it sorta seems different to be
dealing with the representation of the
group than with a group itself.
Yeah,
right.
Definitely the whole interaction,
the demands,
the whole thing seemed to be pretty sure
there's all sorts of other things that
come into play when you're actually
dealing with a person because then it's
a two way.
I mean then you have to give back as
well as receive,
which seems like a part of what you're
describing.
This process of acculturation.
Right?
Right.
And there's other things that come into
play to like sexual tensions and,
and dominance,
hierarchy maneuvering and,
and all sorts of other things that,
that to be part of a community you have
to master.
Yeah.
Um,
I'd always thought of.
Well,
I think that that's just
the way I see it is.
Um,
so I've always been,
will be probably a freshman in college.
I always thought that details aren't
important,
so like to look at that,
what you're saying as a cake,
I always went for the frosty and instead
of instead of like the base of the cake
and I think that it's possible to,
to still add to,
to get a feel for the team.
Um,
but in my experience as an Undergrad,
I think that,
that knowing the details or,
or going through this is downward
process.
Um,
I don't know if it,
if it makes for a steeper slope,
but it does allow you to get.
There's this,
there's this level here that you just
can't get to without,
without this.
Okay.
So now I want you to tie that more
concretely into the discussion that we
just have.
Okay.
Um,
with,
with him,
yeah.
Okay.
So what it seems to me,
what you're saying,
I don't know,
is,
is possibly that it's,
that you don't understand,
they,
you,
you're getting a feel for the,
for the case,
for the frosting.
Um,
and you're saying that maybe you don't
need to have a group,
um,
to,
to have to grow on this individuality.
You can have a mix on it.
Um,
but what I take you to be saying is that
you need to have,
you need to,
you need to know the group fully before
you can go to the highest level of
industry.
Yeah.
Mike,
I guess the way to specify this could be
to say that isn't ignore the county
fair,
fair enough.
Fair enough.
I don't want them to think the don't
have the capacity to interact in a group
that's composed of knowledge that's
implicit and tacit as well as explicit.
Then if you only go for the explicit
knowledge,
then you risk missing the tacit
knowledge.
That's the stuff that's been so embodied
say non verbal behavior,
but people seem to have different levels
of ability of transforming explicit
knowledge into tacit knowledge.
I mean different,
different willingness to do that.
Yeah,
I mean the interplay between the,
the memory systems,
the ability to go down the hierarchy as
well.
Is that right?
Great.
Well we often don't think down and is
necessary.
Right,
and I think that's because we take the
attitude that you just described is that
if you know that if you know the words,
you don't have to know the music,
you don't have to know how to put it
into action.
I think that's.
I think that's part of the reason that
actually by the way that the general
public in the USA,
for example,
holds intellectuals in content is
because we think the fact is the is the
knowledge and that's when you can act
out the fact you're an idiot.
That's why I like woody Allen movies
actually because woody Allen's
characters are just so stuffed full of
facts that it's appalling.
Almost completely useless because they
haven't made the transition down the
hierarchy.
That's right.
Are they confused?
I think what they confuse his knowledge
with wisdom,
it's like,
and that's what academics do in general,
what intellectual students we think
because we know facts that were smart
and that's dumb because knowing useless
facts,
that's stupid.
Yeah.
What about gender bumps or.
So another question about to what extent
if there's inculturation is like
necessarily like,
would you say that in order to be
successful artists and do something new,
you would have to understand all our
thinking before you or could you like
sort of working in isolation still do
something?
Okay,
well look,
that's a tough question because when
you're working in isolation you're not
working in isolation because like say by
the time you're 20 or 21 or whatever and
you're working in isolation,
your,
your head so to speak,
is already stuffed full of your culture
and many of the things that you
discover,
you're actually just remembering like
it's already the presuppositions that I
remember.
Let me give you an example.
The first political science class I took
when I was 17,
I wrote an essay with a friend of mine
that outline the wheat.
We outline the preconditions for an
ideal state.
We thought this was very original piece
of work and we handed this to the
professor and the next week we studied
John Stuart Mill and John Locke and
everything we had written down was in
their writings and I never read John
Stewart neuro or John Law,
but the point is is that what they said
400 years ago,
it's so much part of everything that we
do that even if you don't know,
you know it.
So then if you start thinking about
what,
what constitutes the ideal,
well he ended up doing is recapitulating
what's already been done.
So.
So that's,
that's like one answer to your question.
The other answer is I would say in
general,
keeping in mind Nietzsche's objections
that the more you know about what people
did before you,
the greater your chance of going
somewhere that no one has ever done
before.
Because otherwise you risk reinventing
the wheel.
And it really.
And in a way that's inefficient.
Like Einstein,
I think it was Einstein,
he said,
I can see so far because I stood on the
shoulders of giants and that's,
that's a reference to the Einstein was a
revolutionary,
I mean,
but he still said despite the fact that
I'm a revolutionary and I undermined my
ancestors so to speak,
the only reason I ever got there is
because I knew exactly what they do.
I do.
That's the way to go about it.
One of,
one of the things that seems to be some,
it's awkward to talk about this because
we think independence is good and
dependency is bad and interdependent
sort of is some sort of a liminal
condition.
I mean,
we don't quite know what to do with in
our culture.
It seems to me that some of the unease
of that,
this is related to that,
but I actually wanted to ask about
gender difference in relation to this
process we're talking about and whether
that's significant.
Um,
I don't.
My guess is that at a,
at a fundamental level,
I would say probably not.
Whether there's,
where were you thinking about gender
differences in relationship to the,
the group connection,
that group experience and what the group
experience is like an adolescent?
Oh,
I think there are probably gender
differences in adolescence.
Partly because women hit puberty like
two years earlier than men do.
I think that that makes quite a quite a
big difference.
So there are groups get fragmented
earlier about what difference that
makes.
I don't know,
but I would suspect that it's a severe
enough difference to,
to,
to have some at least short term
implications.
I mean girls hit puberty at 12 or 13,
14 and two years later for boys,
so by the time boys have to deal with
all that,
there are two years older and have two
years more experience.
Also,
I think what happens to girls peer
relationships is that when they hit
puberty,
they start associating immediately with
older boys two or three years older.
Of course then they're immediately put
in a,
at least at temporarily subordinate
position and they don't get a chance to
develop their peer network groups quite
to the same degree.
Whereas boys have to kind of do that by
default,
maybe when they're 13 or whatever,
they'd rather be associated with girls
have their own age,
but the girls will have anything to do
with them,
so it was like while they're off,
they're off together by default.
I don't know what that means in the
final analysis.
I'm
thinking subjectively that
making powerful gender differences in
the entire story all along the line.
Just that could be a topic that might
come back to it at the end of the.
Yeah.
Well if you have ideas about that that
you know,
that would be a really useful topic for
an essay,
for example,
if you want to explore that more
thoroughly because the gender issue is.
Well first of all there is gender
problem,
so to speak.
He looked at classical religious,
western religious traditions.
There's big gender issues occurring
there all the time.
The central figure in Christianity is
male and this is.
This is troublesome for even from the
perspective of ritual invitation,
it's troublesome.
You also.
It also does seem to me the case,
they didn't mythology as a general rule,
the figure of the hero is represented as
masking so and I don't know what that
means for for it doesn't mean that
heroes are map.
It certainly doesn't mean that in a
sense it does because you have to ask
to ask about the culture.
Your culture is represented as the great
father and right to think that we have a
patriarchal culture in the west.
I think we've talked about individual
stories and there are some very
important developmental differences
between boys and girls that I think
we're the last,
maybe in the seventies and eighties we
weren't willing to investigate,
but now maybe we are in the field of
psychology and one of those is that boys
have to need their mothers girls.
Right?
Right.
And a lot of the themes of the course in
terms of the terror like your nephew,
he's terrifying dreams of having to go
out on its own and here or having to
leave and having to kill his mother.
All of these seem to be very tied into
this masculine experience of having to
leave.
One's mother,
for example,
in a lot of monkey colonies,
the unveils how often it's two girls,
right?
The girls don't have to leave.
I think very different developmental
perspective.
It doesn't mean it goes to get along
with them.
Others,
it just means you never expected to make
that break.
Boys are.
You never put in that same position and
I think that it's also the case boy's
initiation.
Rituals tend to be much more violent
than dramatic than those girls and I
think you've said,
I think it is very much for this reason
because there a break that there's a
more severe break that necessarily has
to be made or this has.
This has really profound implications
for the constructions of ideals too
because it seems to me,
this is my own personal opinion of
course,
but it seems to me that the feminist
movement,
especially in the sixties and seventies,
miss the boat in some regards,
bike presuming that the male pattern of
development and construction of the
patriarchal society necessarily
constituted an ideal form of behavior
and one that women would do well to
emulate.
I mean,
you can say that separately from saying
from,
from.
You can say that separately.
Well,
I'm not so sure about that.
okay.
I mean this,
this is an issue obviously,
that there's,
there's all sorts of area for debate,
but that's my general impression.
So anyways,
it's just an absolutely useful,
useful topic and I don't know how to
address it from.
One of the things that's interesting
with regards to this though is that it's
not so much the case in this class,
but most of us students
were women and the appeal of his writing
has generally been to women.
No,
I don't.
Why that is exactly.
I think that's more here relates to
extract information and I think that has
to do a lot with like the historical
moment.
I think that women and men experienced
our historical moment,
adolescent funimation identity in such
different ways.
Like due to a large project managers
yanked away from their mothers,
his boys and then they have to go
through this initiatory.
Right?
And then they see women no longer his
mother but his mate,
you know,
for reproduction to Marin and perpetuate
society or whatever.
So the point being is that not only j,
they have very different experiences so
that like the feminist movement,
you know,
you can't parallelize the woman's
experience to a man's experience so that
like the way young interprets,
you know,
life is just,
it's more effective to a woman because,
you know,
he deals with women are socialized in
much different ways that you can deal
with issues relating much more to a
women as a woman does,
where history is like,
you know,
historically dominated by men and man
creates history.
So what do you think it is about his
writings and make making in particular
more attractive to women?
I mean,
they're,
they're so interesting to me.
They're just fascinating because I think
it's just because it's more,
um,
I don't know,
maybe you know,
you're sold or you know,
it's just,
it's not really something you can
articulate very well.
But,
um,
I guess just his references to um,
well,
you,
you believe that you don't believe that
the idea of thinking of how things were
connected was more intrinsically
attracted women than the idea of things
of how things are different.
And the masculine consciousness has a
discriminative quality which cuts things
into pieces and I think that might be.
I think that might because males are
more bilaterally split in there
hemisphere as well.
I mean,
I don't know.
I don't know that the idea that that
represents.
I mean I know that that's not,
that's somewhat speculative in terms of
physiology,
but the,
the idea of the strength of the
masculine identity with the semantic
system.
Well that's a,
that's a possibility.
I mean,
if I was going to speculate in their
direction,
that's probably the path down which I
would go.
So
what's that?
Smaller?
Yeah,
I think that's.
I think that's the case.
Okay.
One other thing,
I just wanna I to pop some ideas out
with relationship to this before we
close out the class because I really
want you to think about this because
this is important.
Um,
look,
you know,
if you're,
if you're searching for information
about how to behave well,
that's a search for wisdom.
And the question that sort of underlies
the search for wisdom is an internal
philosophical question.
Then the question is what is the good.
And I try to make something of this and
this manuscript because I think that
posing the question in that way has
caused us a lot of trouble.
Now I would say that like if you're
here,
okay,
so mom's gone,
you know you're not a child anymore and
you can't,
she can't solve your problems anymore.
And that has,
that's just the way it is.
You're too big.
So then you're here in this chaotic
intermediary position and someone comes
along and this is what initiation
rituals do.
They tear the boys and the women all cry
because the boys are gone and when they
come back they're going to be again.
And that's the truth.
So when they acquitted,
they cried,
they made it.
The boys are taken out away from their
mother and they're terrified half to
death,
which is basically what happens to
marines.
We need to put through bootcamp.
And then for precisely the same raises,
it's like you're no longer child will
put you through the ringer.
Your old identities.
No,
it has to be killed.
We'll kill it because it's better than
it dies now than that.
It hangs around with 20 years torturing,
which is what it would do otherwise,
so we'll just scare the hell out of you
and put you in a very suggestible state
and what would have suggested estate
paid?
Well,
I would say I'm going to strip away all
your past beliefs and put you in a
situation you've never been in before,
which is to say you've always been
afraid of the dark,
but mom was always there,
so now I'm going to do is find the
darkest and most frightening place that
I can possibly imagine and I'm going to
put you in it,
and that's what people do and initiation
ceremonies.
It's like,
here's a.
here's a case.
You don't know what the hell is in it.
Maybe there's a monster.
In fact,
there is one that your imagination is
put there and it's the worst monster you
can think of.
That's where you're going,
so we're going to put you in there till
till you discover that although you feel
that you're going to go crazy,
you won't.
That's your heightened state of
suggestibility is I'm in a place where
nothing makes sense and put me because
I've never felt this before.
What do I want?
I want an answer.
Well,
that's when inculturation of course,
it's like you're no longer a child.
Here's the mysteries of the tribe.
That's your new story.
That's brainwashing.
We proceeded so you're all chaotic.
You want me to story including one that
will cover everything that you just
experienced.
Someone comes along and hands it to you
on a silver plate.
You take it in,
that's your inculturation.
So now you're an adult and your standard
bear of the community.
So you could say,
well,
the question here is being a child is no
longer an answer to your problem.
So the next problem is what is the good?
And that's conceived of as a concrete
question and their answer is our
culture.
So that's where the human being Smith
and many cultures,
the word many cultures used for the
members of that culture is the word
that's the equivalent to human,
which is that if you're from this
culture,
you're human.
If you're from another culture,
but whatever you are isn't human.
For me,
it's something that's sort of looks like
but partakes more of the domain of
novelty than of the domain of the
encountered.
So
given culture is a specific answer to
the general question.
What is the good,
and it's the question that's answered
when you make the transition from
childhood to adolescence.
We know that,
that an answer to the question,
what is the goodest troublesome say in
the Old Testament,
for example,
it says,
shouldn't make an idol out of God.
That's right.
No graven images.
And why is that?
Because you shouldn't confuse the
abstract thing with the concrete thing
and the problem with the question,
what is the good,
which is a question that western
philosophy is being trained to address
4,000 years,
is that it presumes that there is an
answer to a question like that,
which is to say that in the way the
question is phrased,
there's an implicit presumption that it
can be answered in that form and I would
say that when you adopt a group
identity,
that's what you've answered,
but there is a better question and it's
the question that you answered when you
make it to the next step.
So you say,
well,
chaos group identification,
Bang,
that's your solution.
What is the good?
Well,
here's a whole bunch of rules,
right?
Those are concrete representations of
how you should behave and what
constitutes good and evil from a
particular perspective,
but then there's another question that
might rear its ugly head later,
which is a much more profound question
and that is the question.
What is the nature of the process?
By which answers to the question,
what is the good are formulated,
right?
It's a medical question,
it says not what's the answer to the
question,
but what's the nature of the procedure
that you engage in when you're answering
the questions which you really have to
know because the question what is the
good shifts with environmental
circumstance,
which is to say that what's good for you
one day is not necessarily good for you
the next day or what's good for your
culture now like do it in 100 years.
So if you answered the question,
what is the good with an answer,
then you've already made an error
because the answer presupposes that
there isn't permanent answer to that
question and that's wrong.
So I would say
when you get to this level of the whole
system,
which is the next stage beyond your
cultural identification,
what you're looking for,
is it a description of the process that
leads you to be able to answer questions
of the sort?
What is when you have to update them
constantly.
And so I would say that why do you
identify with when you moved to here is
the process by which these structures
are actually January.
So it's the process that you read
stories itself and that that gives you
all the wisdom that you already have as
a consequence of your cultural
identification with the additional
knowledge that you're also the one that
builds the stories.
That's where your central point of
identification can be.
So then if you say you're involved in,
in,
in settling a dispute between people
from two different cultural positions.
And the thing is,
you know,
you know that person a and person b are
both exemplary
representatives of their particular
culture,
but they're at odds with one another.
So then the question then is,
well,
what constitutes common ground?
Because you need a position.
Remember we were asking and wondering
what's the,
what's the issue?
Here's one story.
Here's another.
They're not the same as a consequence
like traveling is breaking out.
Well we don't know what going to
maneuver over here where there are no
rules.
It's great because neither side excepts
the rules on the other side.
So then the question is,
well,
what are the rules that allow you to
maneuver when you're outside the place
that there are rules?
And I would say,
well,
I would hope that I could appeal to you
on a general basis and as someone who's
not only an exemplar of the culture as
specified territory,
but an exemplar of those members of the
culture who had enough courage to
construct the culture to begin with,
and that's the place where we hope to
operate.
And then I would also hope to be able to
say to you that your culture differs
from my culture,
but were there the same is that they
were both directed by people who had
enough courage to erect.
And so if you really want to identify
with your culture,
then you stop identifying with the rules
and you start identifying with the
process and also to the degree that you
want me to identify with the rules,
you stop yourself from identifying with
the process.
Most people are not those courageous
people.
Well,
I think partly it's a problem of
conceptualization is that until you can
perceive the possibility.
Look,
if you want to stop kids,
for example,
from,
uh,
from forming gangs and from proceeding
morally within the game.
But immorally with regards to the rest
of the world,
I don't think that saying to them,
well,
the way that you construct your game is
inappropriate.
It's going to work because they need the
gangs,
but what you might be able to say as
well what you think you,
you think what you're doing is the most
courageous thing that can be done
because a lot of gang activity,
for example,
is quite dangerous.
But then you say,
well,
it's not his.
There's a whole other realm of courage.
It's outside of the domain that you've
considered.
It's much more difficult and if you are
a real human being,
so to speak,
that's what you do.
Because if you want to offer someone an
option and have them take it,
I think you have to offer them something
that's more difficult.
The moral equivalent board or if that's
right,
that's the moral equivalent of war.
Yeah,
absolutely.
But the problem is something that's just
as excited and just as dangerous.
But where did the territory's different?
The problem is worried something
procedural and therefore it's easy to
grasp as an alternative.
Whereas this is something that's
correct.